antes de comenzar a ver las cosas más
cercanas que se encuentran fuera de
nuestro sistema solar
quisiera que regresáramos unos pasos y
viéramos a nuestro sol como en la imagen
que tenemos aquí que para mí es algo
tremendo porque a esta escala el sol se
ve como un objeto enorme y la tierra
tendría aproximadamente este tamaño
para mí es tremenda la idea de que todo
nuestro planeta cabe completamente en
una de estas llamaradas de plasma que
expulsa el sol imaginen aunque en
realidad nunca podríamos verlo a simple
vista si tuviéramos una nave que nos
protegiera cómo sería estar en este tipo
de ambiente es un concepto fascinante
pero haciendo nuestro lado que
significaría encontrarnos en el límite
del sistema solar
en el vídeo anterior exploramos la nube
de oort que comienza a poco menos de un
año luz de distancia del sol pero
dependiendo de lo que ustedes consideren
el límite del sistema solar podría estar
un poco más lejos o podría estar tan
lejos como la nube de oort en el sol se
expulsan estas cosas pero hay incluso
partículas que no podemos ver
electrones y protones de súper alta
energía que también son inyectados por
el sol a velocidades tremendamente
grandes a 400 kilómetros por segundo
vamos a escribirlo 400 kilómetros por
segundo en la tierra estamos protegidos
de estas partículas de alta energía por
el campo magnético de la tierra pero en
la superficie de la luna cuando el sol
está en lo alto es decir no estamos en
el lado oscuro de la luna tendremos
contacto directo con estas partículas
por lo que se imaginarán que no es algo
muy bueno estar ahí por mucho tiempo
pero la razón por la que estamos
hablando de esto de estas partículas
cargadas que salen con velocidades
tremendas de la superficie del sol a las
que conocemos como viento solar y lo de
viento lo pongo entre comillas porque es
muy diferente a lo que nosotros
conocemos como viento que normalmente
asociamos con una brisa agradable
estas son partículas cargadas que viajan
a velocidades tremendas desde el sol y
estamos viendo esto del viento solar
porque nos puede ayudar con una
definición del límite del sistema solar
que sería el límite hasta donde llega el
viento solar antes de confrontarse con
el medio interestelar aquí tenemos una
imagen que ilustra este concepto la nube
de oort o al menos el borde más denso se
encuentra mucho más lejos que esto aquí
tenemos a la nave voyager 1 y apoya ayer
2 si queremos ver la órbita de cessna en
la parte más cercana está de aquí y por
acá si alejaría pero la nube de oort
estaría más lejana
esta es una imagen del sistema solar
como la extensión del viento solar que
es más pequeña que la nube de orden pero
aún así es bastante grande aquí tenemos
la heliopausa lo saque de wikipedia esto
en esencia es donde la velocidad y la
fuerza del viento solar son
contrarrestadas o podemos verlo como que
la presión aquí ha disminuido tanto que
es contrarrestada por el hidrógeno y el
helio que se encuentran en el medio
interestelar que está afuera
después de este punto ya no avanza más y
se queda en pausa las naves voyager 1 y
hoy ayer 2 se encuentran bastante cerca
de esta frontera por lo que las personas
piensan que se encuentran en la frontera
del sistema solar aunque nunca tendremos
un borde o límite definido de esto otra
forma de verlo es que la nube de oort o
el lugar en donde agua podemos encontrar
objetos aunque aún no hemos podido
observar los objetos de la nube de oort
directamente sólo pensamos que están ahí
quizás la definición más abstracta es
aquella hasta dónde llega la influencia
gravitatoria del sol todas estas son
formas de imaginarnos hasta dónde llega
la extinción del sistema solar pero
todas ellas tienen un área gris acerca
de lo que está y no está en el sistema
solar pero lo que quiero hacer es hablar
de lo que se encuentra afuera del
sistema solar esto nos sirvió para
darnos una idea de la escala necesaria
para llegar a la estrella más cercana
ahora veamos esta imagen de nuestro
vecindario estelar y aún cuando estas
estrellas se ven muy grandes
este es nuestro sistema solar pero esto
no es el sol si quisiéramos dibujar aquí
al sol no alcanzaríamos a iluminar
ningún píxel de la imagen de hecho la
órbita entera de tutor y todo lo que
está adentro tampoco alcanzaría iluminar
un solo píxel de la imagen lo que vemos
aquí tiene el radio de un año luz de
distancia sería más o menos el radio de
la nube de oort y en el vídeo anterior
vimos lo enorme que es especialmente
comparada con el radio de la órbita de
plutón
que estaría más o menos por acá
este es por sí mismo un diámetro muy
grande una gran distancia al sol
pero no hay luminaria ni un píxel en
este diagrama de aquí
esto es para darnos una idea de qué tan
lejos estamos somos un puntito dentro de
otro puntito el pixel de un píxel en el
centro de aquí así que la distancia
digamos desde la tierra hacia la
estrella más cercana o al conjunto de
estelar más cercano que es alfa centauri
es un grupo de estrellas que son alfa
centauri
que es la más grande
alfa centauri ve y otra que no podemos
observar a simple vista que es proxima
centauri que es una estrella más pequeña
es la estrella más cercana y la
distancia al más cercano de este grupo
es de 4.2 años luz
otra forma de verlo es que si alguien
dirigiera un rayo de luz suponiendo que
pudiéramos ver dicho rayo de luz este
rayo tardaría en que lo viéramos 4.2
años y si este rayo desapareciera o se
apagará no nos enteraremos hasta dentro
de 4.2 años y quizás piensen que no está
tan lejos podríamos viajar ahí y ver si
hay algún ser vivo allá que pudiéramos
conocer y con quien pudiéramos
intercambiar tecnología pero esta es una
distancia enorme estos 4.2 años-luz
representan una distancia ridículamente
grande todo esto es para darnos una idea
de lo que voy a hacer 1 y 2 que vimos en
el vídeo anterior han recorrido casi han
llegado a la heliopausa
estas naves viajan a 60 mil kilómetros
por hora
que son 17 kilómetros por segundo
si pudiéramos viajar a esa velocidad que
estas naves lograron mediante el impulso
gravitatorio de ciertos planetas más
grandes y así lograr esta aceleración
pues estas velocidades no son fáciles de
conseguir pero si pudiéramos viajar a
estas velocidades y viajamos en
dirección del grupo de alfa centauri nos
llevaría 80 mil años llegar a este grupo
de estrellas si viajáramos a la
velocidad de voy ayer 1 que es la nave
más rápida de las voy ayer es una
cantidad de tiempo ridículamente grande
por lo que tendríamos que encontrar una
mejor manera de hacer esto